the beautiful bay above tree or tree of  life is an African icon the bail Bob  fruit contains four times the potassium  of banana three times the vitamin C 1  orange and twice the calcium of spinach  but the bail Bob is an orphan science  has paid little attention to this tree  until now the African orphan crops  consortium is harnessing the power of  genetics for orphan crops the bail Bob  tree is the first of 101 plants to have  its genome sequence assembled and  annotated and the information will be  made available to all unrestricted where  millions of people are malnourished this  genetic data will help farmers provide  the food they need the genomes will  guide African plant breeders so they can  create crops that are higher yielding  water and nutrient you sufficient  resilient to climate change and full of  nutrition triggering a huge leap forward  for the diversity and sustainability of  the continents agriculture  you